[Music]
[Applause]
on July 5th 2015 I woke up in Vancouver
and immediately sprinted to the bathroom
to look at myself in the mirror I was
very happy to see that my hair dye had
stayed in overnight and to me it was the
perfect shade of bright blue so you may
be wondering why on a random summer day
in Canada I decided to dye my hair blue
but there's actually a good reason I
love soccer I especially love the US
Women's National Team who was playing
the World Cup Finals on that day and my
friends and I were preparing to go a few
hours later we entered the packed
stadium and we're immediately surrounded
by 50,000 other diehard fans decked out
either USA or Japan colors although in
my opinion my friends and I definitely
had the most team spirit what struck me
when I entered the stadium was that
women's soccer finally seems relevant it
finally seems important with every goal
that Carli Lloyd or another member of
the team scored the crowd got more and
more energized when the final whistle
blew determining the u.s. women to be
world champions every single person in
that stadium felt a wave of emotion to
me it felt as if people actually cared
about women's soccer and that female
athletes in the United States would
finally have an opportunity to make a
living off of their talent like the men
do the hard work and determination of
the 24 women on that national team led
them to become heroes for me and so many
other girls around the world with so
many people looking up to them I just
assumed that these women were being well
rewarded for their commitment and their
success but as it turns out I was
entirely wrong about that I'm Stu
discovered that when a men's team was
eliminated from the first round of the
World Cup in 2014 they were rewarded
with 8 million dollars from FIFA the
u.s. women's team rendering more views
than any American soccer game for either
gender ever received a mere two million
dollars I don't think that anyone can
look at those numbers and not see the
injustice
the men's champion in 2014 Germany
received 35 million dollars from FIFA 33
million dollars more than me equally as
successful women of the United States
this unfortunate reality of pay inequity
for women soccer players doesn't only
apply to the national team but also to
the National Women's Soccer League in
the United States the minimum salary for
a professional women's soccer player and
the United States is six thousand eight
hundred and forty two dollars
comparatively the minimum salary in the
MLS the men's soccer league in the
United States is sixty thousand dollars
not only Israel major Japanese numbers
but the women's minimum salary is far
below the poverty line these are just a
few of the alarming statistics that show
the evident wage gap between male and
female soccer players in the United
States now some of you may have seen on
the news recently that a few members of
the US Women's National Team issued a
complaint to the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission or EEOC they
argue that US soccer is violating the
Equal Employment Act in title 7 by
discriminating against the women based
on their gender in a recent interview on
60 minutes team captain Carli Lloyd
stated we feel as if we are being
treated as second-class citizens because
they do not care as much about us as
they do the men the amount of money that
these hard-working women are being paid
is not sufficient and change is
imperative I cannot imagine my own life
without soccer soccer has taught me
countless lessons and I know that I'm a
more confident driven person because of
it when I was younger I dreamed of
playing professional soccer I know that
there's a lot of young girls out there
today who have that same dream oblivious
to the reality of achieving their goal
who is supposed to tell those little
girls that becoming a professional
soccer player means they'll be faced
with discrimination that they'll make
less money for doing the exact same work
as men that they'll be forced to work in
worse conditions and facilities women I
know that I do not want to be the one to
tell those little girls those things I
want to tell them to dream big
being a professional soccer player means
it can make a living off of their
passion I want to tell them to work hard
because their hard work will be rewarded
with adequate pay but today I cannot
tell those little girls as things gender
discrimination is still a major problem
in our world today but I know that I
want to do any little thing that I can
to help stop this problem
soccer is just one starting place but it
is a place that we can start so you may
be wondering how do we start well
according to the EEOC and their response
to the complaint issued by the few
members of the US Women's National Team
the reason that US soccer pays the men
more than the women it's because the men
have higher TV ratings and higher ticket
sales
the part about ticket sales has proved
not to be true this year because a 60
Minutes reporter Norah O'Donnell
mentioned in her interview with a few
members of the US Women's National Team
u.s. soccer's own projections show that
this year the u.s. women's national team
will net about five million dollars in
ticket sales while the u.s. men's
national team will lose about a million
dollars
that being said the part about the men's
TV ratings being higher than the women's
is definitely true for the most part
there's more interest for men's soccer
so more people are walking those games
on TV giving the EEOC an excuse to let
us soccer pay the men more than the
women
one reason that men's games have higher
TV ratings in the women's is because in
general their games are more competitive
the women are the United States have
established themselves to be the best
team in the world making them cross a
lot of their opponents and making a lot
of people lose interest in watching
their games on TV even me a huge soccer
fan sometimes finds myself
deciding not to watch their games on TV
because I know that they're going to
dominate the region of the u.s. women's
team has been so dominant it's because
in the United States there's far more
access to girls youth soccer than in
other countries there are countless
competitive girls soccer league United
States like the one I grew up playing
earns and these leagues are training
girls to be champions but in other
countries there's hardly any opportune
for young girls to play soccer for many
reasons including lack of funding and
negative stereotypes for girls soccer
players I believe that in order for the
women's soccer TV ratings to go up and
for the EEOC to finally force us soccer
to pay the women as much as the men
other countries must establish
competitive girls soccer leagues there
are a few ways to begin to push for
creating girls soccer leagues in other
countries first is to get men's clubs
that already exist in these countries to
recognize the economic gain that adding
a girls league would bring a good
example of this is in Spain where
recently a few soccer a few men's soccer
clubs have added a girl side big soccer
clubs there like Barcelona FC have girls
training league that eventually feed
into a professional team for the best
players the reason at Barcelona FC and
these other clubs have a girl side is
because the girls reek generates revenue
for the club more men's soccer clubs
around the world need to understand that
adding a girl's league is a smart
economic move so that there will be more
competitive girls soccer leagues around
the world another reason that a lot of
countries don't have competitive girls
soccer leagues is because girls that are
interested in other sports due to a lack
of exposure to women's soccer lots of
these countries do have women's national
teams but these teams hardly have any
attention in the country this is
entirely the opposite from the men's
teams to enjoy tons of media attention
TV play and time in the spotlight one
way for women's national teams in other
countries to get more attention is for
popular companies in these countries to
use the female athletes from these teams
in their marketing campaigns in the
United States certain companies have
made progress in this department such as
nationwide and Nike using Alex Morgan
and their commercials if other companies
around the world used female athletes
from the soccer teams in their marketing
campaigns this could be the start to
popularizing the game for women with
more demand for girls soccer more men's
clubs would add a girls league if there
are more competitive girls soccer
leagues around the world these countries
would be able to produce female athletes
who perform at the elite level
to compete with the US Women's National
Team once the US Women's National Team
has more competition their games will be
a lot more exciting and more people will
want to watch the games on TV this will
cause the TV ratings to go up and the
EEOC will no longer have an excuse to
let us soccer pay the women less than
the men
the women on the u.s. national team
would finally get to pay that they
deserve it is time for equal pay for men
and women to be present in everything
not just soccer but I have hope that if
we start here this will spread around
the country and around the world to
promote gender equality everywhere where
there is equal play there needs to be
equal pay thank you
[Applause]